votre rendez-vous politique du dimanche
soir sur Radio sensation en association
avec TV 78 épisode 225 nous sommes au
Parlement européen de Strasbourg et mon
invité et la député européenne Mathilde
Androuet
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes depuis 2019 député
européenne membre du groupe
identité et démocratie au Parlement
européen élu sur la liste de Jordan
Bardella du rassemblement national alors
les mouvements souverainistes se sont
renforcés lors des dernières élections
en Europe des coalitions allant de la
droite à l'extrême droite sont désormais
au pouvoir en Suède avec les démocrates
de Suède de Jimmy Axson ou en Italie
aussi c'est Georgia Meloni et ils sont
partis Fratelli Italia qui l'ont emporté
alors deux élections historiques comment
est-ce que vous voulez avez accueillis
vous en tant que député européenne
depuis Strasbourg
alors c'est toujours très intéressant de
voir qu'il y a une mobilisation des
Européens pour apprendre reprendre un
peu en main leur destin c'est vraiment
ce qui caractérise un peu je pense tous
nos mouvements malgré des fois leurs
différences de sensibilité sur des
sujets très précis économiques très
locaux et on associe au moins en commun
c'est la volonté de défendre nos nations
et ça c'est très heureux de voir que
l'attente c'est vraiment une histoire de
contrecarrer la tendance fâcheuse de
l'Union européenne qui d'une vision
fédérale de promanant le pas qui prend
et bien non manger par une vision
purement impérialiste et donc le c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est de se dire
que les Européens ont compris qu'une
bonne partie de leur quotidien était
gérée très très loin d'eux à savoir
Bruxelles et même pas Bruxelles dans la
Parlement européen mais burcell
commission avec des gens non élus et
donc le but du jeu est aussi de
réinsuffler un peu de démocratie et de
vivacité politique en Europe donc ça
c'était très plaisant et plutôt
encourageant je pense pour
la respiration européenne alors certains
en décryptant cette victoire ils ont vu
des une forme d'union des droites en
France certains à droite militent aussi
pour ce choix est-ce que cette union des
droites devrait se faire en 2027 on l'a
vu à gauche en tout cas ils l'ont fait
avec la nups pour les législatives en
disant
c'est trop droit donc alors qu'ici on
aurait plutôt une fâcheuse tendance à la
qualifier d'extrêmement donc c'est je
préfère pas rentrer dans le genre
d'union moi je pense à l'union des
patriotes qui viennent de droite comme
de gauche je pense que rassemblement
national on a depuis longtemps prôné le
dépassement de cette section droite et
gauche selon les sujets on peut
peut-être nous situer à droite selon
d'autres plus à gauche à dire vrai moi
je fais partie d'une génération qui est
complètement indifférente à cette
classification
je pense que oui et d'ailleurs je pense
que le clivage se fait plutôt entre ceux
qui défendent la nation et ceux qui
défendent le système mondialiste et
d'ailleurs ça se voit même nous alors en
France c'est très clair c'est à dire que
vous avez système Macron complètement
ancré dans le monde d'après le
dépassement de la France et ceux qui
croient encore à la France et au
potentiel des Français à savoir nous et
ça s'est vu dans la configuration de
l'élection présidentielle
la nups du coup
[Rires]
mais avec
malgré tout en au sein de leur
groupement une sorte de trahison de se
dépenser de l'originalité que pouvait
être la gauche c'est à dire que pour moi
historiquement la gauche c'est quand
même la défense du petit peuple mais du
peuple et je pense que ils sont
complètement sortis de ce qui était leur
mission historique à savoir la défense
du peuple la ministre français des
Affaires européennes Laurence Boone a
dit lors d'une interview dans le journal
la République la France sera très
vigilante sur le respect des valeurs et
des règles de l'État de droit en Italie
et que l'Union européenne avait déjà
démontré sa ville gigance à l'égard
d'autres pays comme la Hongrie la
Pologne dont les fonds européens sont
destinés aussi à assez pays et sont
régulièrement remis en cause qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de de cette interview de
la ministre de Laurence Boone est-ce que
c'est pour vous de l'ingérence
qui fait la leçon à un peuple entier un
peuple italien qui fait un peu voilà ce
qui est pas un peuple comme tous les
autres pas méprisable voilà dont on doit
respecter les opinions donc pour qui se
prend-elle et pour qui se prend aussi
parfois en effet l'Union européenne
c'est à dire que de faire la leçon à des
pays entiers à des peuples entiers qui
ont choisi leur politique qui ont choisi
leur stratégie elle leur convient elle
nous convient pas peu importe ils l'ont
choisi c'est ça la démocratie des fois
ça fait pas toujours plaisir la
démocratie mais ça fait pas par plaisir
à ses propres convictions
elle sort complètement de son rôle et
par ailleurs je la trouve même parfois
indécente comme là on l'a vu récemment à
vouloir couper les fonds par exemple de
la Pologne au prétexte qu'elle ne serait
pas complètement raccord avec la
Commission européenne alors même qu'elle
a elle accueille parmi les dizaines de
milliers des réfugiés ukrainiens et donc
même pour ça elle n'a pas eu d'aide
alors même qu'elle est aux portes de ce
conflit qui nous emporte tous en ce
moment
le sommet de Prague on va y revenir
c'est espacer les 6 et 7 octobre dernier
a parmi le lancement d'une communauté
politique européenne une nouvelle
instance chargée de ne pas laisser de
côté les autres pays européens un forum
diplomatique comme on le nom alors parmi
lesquels donc le Royaume-Uni la Suisse
aussi les pays des Balkans et ont
participé mais aussi la Turquie
l'Ukraine et aussi l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan qui sont d'ailleurs en
plein conflit
celle deux absences sont à constater la
Russie et la Biélorussie
c'était une façon de montrer l'unité du
continent européen face à Vladimir
Poutine et de lancer un huitième paquet
de sanctions aussi de la part de l'Union
européenne envers la Russie vous au
rassemblement national si j'ai bien
compris vous estimez que les sanctions
elles ne sont pas efficaces elles vont
parfois être trop loin et ne sont pas
dans l'intérêt des Français c'est ça
surtout quand elles pas ajuster hyper
idéologique en fait c'est ça mon souci
c'est à dire que une sanction n'a
d'intérêt que si elle sanctionne et en
l'occurrence le l'objectif était de
fonctionner la Russie or là la Russie
s'enrichit à hauteur de près de 40
milliards concernant ne serait-ce que la
distribution de d'énergie et pendant ce
temps ça nous nos factures d'électricité
explosent s'envolent de même pour le
prix du pétrole qui est juste en ce
moment en France juguler par l'Aristote
gouvernementale mais c'est juste un
parapluie avant la tempête et je donc
c'est pour moi c'est un échec décider
comme ça de sanctions totalement
disproportionnée et qui finalement aide
le la personne que vous étiez sur
supposé sanctionner c'est un voilà c'est
un échec donc il faut revenir sur ça
parce qu'en attendant ce sont les
Européens qui en pâtissent c'était aussi
l'occasion pour l'UE de confirmer
l'envoi d'une mission civile en Arménie
le long de l'Azerbaïdjan pourrait aider
à délimiter les frontières autant le
conflit que serait ukrainien on en parle
tous les jours quasiment dans les médias
mais sur le conflit entre l'Azerbaïdjan
et l'Arménie on en parle un petit peu
moins est-ce que
pourquoi est-ce que comment est-ce que
vous expliquez que l'Union européenne
est un peu plus discrète sur sur ce que
je pense que
[Musique]
elle a eu une capacité d'inder
d'indignation très aléatoire c'est en
fonction de ses propres intérêts voilà
donc elle veut récupérer de l'énergie de
l'Azerbaïdjan donc on peut donc l'argent
peut écraser les Arméniens d'une manière
absolument atroce et terrible parce
qu'on parle tout le temps de crimes de
guerre mais il serait heureux de se
pencher sur le cas des Arméniens qui est
gravissime qui est une attente
permanente au droit humain donc oui
j'attends un peu plus que des petites
lunéième commission un énième comité
Théodule là il faut il faut être ferme
et ça va être très ferme j'ai entendu
des choses absolument terribles en
février lors de
l'attaque russe contre l'Ukraine
j'attends une même fermeté en fait à
dire vrai en tout cas à minima au moins
dans les verbes
on va revenir sur le les conséquences de
la crise économique en vue de la
situation en Russie
cette crise énergétique en Europe il
faut donc repenser les stratégies au
niveau européen
en termes d'approvisionnement aussi
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé vous
du plan de sobriété énergétique du
gouvernement donc baisser la température
chez soi laisser le robinet sur l'eau
froide baisser la température du
chauffe-eau sont des mesures de bon sens
ou finalement ça infantilise
à quelle heure je dois prendre ma douche
à quelle heure je dois doucher les
enfants les faire manger et me faire la
pub des pubs d'Amar en fait c'est
j'attends autre chose un premier
ministre concrètement c'est dérisoire on
ne change pas
la structure même de notre marché
énergétique
cette espèce de truc n'est absolument
délirant pour des Français qui
pourraient être indépendants et
souverain si on développait notre
filière nucléaire on n'avait pas laissé
mourir si on n'avait pas non plus
privatisé depuis Fillon mais entériné
par Macron nos barrages hydroélectriques
c'est juste voilà c'est un une gestion
totalement délirante du notre
souveraineté énergétique et de là nous
le payons aujourd'hui c'est juste
hallucinant qu'on soit art et que notre
le prix de notre électricité soit arrimé
sur le marché du gaz alors même que la
France peut être totalement indépendante
du marché du gaz puisqu'on arrive à
assurer notre souveraineté énergétique
par d'autres
au niveau du gaz sur la Russie
le mix énergétique allemand qui mélange
éolien et forcément gaz puisque c'est un
mix qui va ensemble créer une dépendance
vis-à-vis de la Russie que nous
subissons alors même que nous pouvons
être totalement souverain en la matière
et pour ça il faut avoir une filière
nucléaire forte ne pas fermer les
programmes tels Astrid qui sont des
programmes d'avenir et éviter des trucs
purement idéologiques de fermeture de
Fessenheim par exemple alors justement
on va revenir sur le gaz comment
remplacer le gaz russe la France avant
la avant la guerre le gaz russe
représentait 17% de la consommation de
gaz c'était donc le premier fournisseur
c'était la Norvège alors récemment la
France mais aussi l'Espagne se sont
tournés vers l'Algérie pour le gaz
l'Allemagne elle recevait 55% de son gaz
de Russie elle se tourne désormais vers
les pays du Golfe comme l'Arabie
Saoudite les Émirats arabes unis autre
solution se tournaient vers les
États-Unis ou encore vous l'avez
mentionné avant laserbaïdjan selon pour
vous quel devrait être la stratégie de
la France en matière de gaz ou on doit
s'approvisionner je pense déjà que la
stratégie de la France c'est de défendre
sa propre souveraineté c'est à dire
s'extraire du marché du gaz en fait
parce que le marché du gaz et forcément
un marché interdépendant et donc
dépendre les États-Unis qui peuvent ce
qui est en plus là aussi un délire
environnemental profond c'est à dire je
ne veux plus jamais recevoir une leçon
d'écologie de la part de gens qui font
la promotion du marché du gaz en fait
qui vient en transport depuis les années
en bateau comme ça on passe notre temps
à parler de la carbonation de nos
économies bon bah soit allez des
carbonnous il faut absolument défendre
notre filière nucléaire la France et en
plus c'était la première au monde là
dessus et nous n'avons de U de 16 de
reculer sur ces sujets là et c'est un
pour moi c'est un désastre industriel
mais c'est aussi aujourd'hui un des
astres social parce que voilà tant qu'on
peut pas remplir
son réservoir dans sa voiture quand on
peut pas alors là pour le coup c'est
l'essence c'est un autre sujet mais
quand on peut pas non plus se chauffer
ou décider de ça enfin pour la macronie
débarque en l'occurrence ça fait déjà
plusieurs années que certains Français
hésitent entre prendre du repas ou se
chauffer en hiver donc il faut moi
j'apprendre énormément cet hiver là s'il
est rude d'apprendre régulièrement dans
la presse et grainer des couples de
vieilles personnes âgées voilà des
périssons dans leur ferme des choses qui
sont absolument sordides socialement
parlant du fait de l'incompétence et de
la responsabilité de nos gouvernement
donc du coup pas les États-Unis pour le
gaz mais enfin
l'objet de notre objectif c'est de
sortir de là donc en attendant
évidemment négocie il y a seulement que
depuis hier que Macron soudainement
proposé que ça devrait peut-être le coup
d'utiliser l'Union européenne comme
force de négociation de gaz en gros en
fait de marcher de gaz en gros mais oui
évidemment ça c'est une idée européenne
quel est l'intérêt d'être tous unis si
ce être uni dans ce genre d'adversité en
effet essayer de négocier des packs
entre guillemets importants tous
ensemble en étant une seule et même
entité mais l'Union européenne n'audité
finalement que dans l'idéologie que
quand il s'agit de condamner de manière
un peu bête certains tel pays tel
politique ou la Hongrie enfin voilà
quand il s'agit vraiment d'en rentrer
dans le dur et d'être uni là qu'on
roulement sur le mari la question du gaz
bah il y a que seulement depuis hier
qu'on se pose la question de l'intérêt
d'avoir l'achat groupé sur la question
du nucléaire pour finir sur cette partie
européenne on va refaire un petit point
sur les chiffres 32 réacteurs sont
actuellement à l'arrêt sur 56 actifs en
France ça fait craindre quelques
blackout cet été mais RTE exclu tous les
risques alors si les Français font
preuve de sobriété normalement le il n'y
aura pas de blackout le nucléaire ça
fait était en tout cas l'un des débats
de la présidentielle en 2022 depuis
l'Union européenne inscrit le nucléaire
dans la taxonomie verte ça veut dire que
européen pourront subventionner cette
filière aujourd'hui ce que vous estimez
que ce débat a été déjà tranché sur le
nucléaire et qu'il faut investir
massivement et notamment via ces fonds
européens dans cette filière j'attends
toujours la concrétisation notamment de
l'arrivée de ses fonds au soutien de la
filière nucléaire pour la simple et
bonne raison que les questions
environnementales notamment au sein de
la Commission européenne et l'Union
européenne en général sont globalement
très noyautées par des lobbies allemands
qui eux-mêmes ça c'est le Canard
Enchaîné qui a sorti le morceau il y a
peu eux-mêmes largement financés par des
enfin des entreprises gazières russes
parce qu'évidemment c'est un mix et
énergétique qui va ensemble donc mais je
serai ravie en effet que la filière
nucléaire profite
enfin à la France mais au reste aussi au
reste de l'Europe parce que c'est une
manière aussi de d'assurer une pérennité
énergétique énergétique qui me semble
être indispensable et de enfin de briser
ce tabou européen qui il faut absolument
la concurrence partout de l'interpoque
finalement de l'interdépendance mondiale
et je pense que c'est le meilleur moyen
de faire mourir nos industries donc en
l'occurrence plus on s'occupe nous-mêmes
de reconstruire notre industrie de
développer nos filières plus on a de
chances de sauver notre avenir en fait
c'est le moment de passer à la deuxième
partie de l'émission politique
toujours avec Mathilde rouet député
européenne du rassemblement national
avant d'être député européenne vous
étiez conseillère régional
d'Île-de-France et élu donc des Yvelines
quelles sont les principaux changements
qu'il peut y avoir entre un mandat des
lieux régional et ce mandat de député
européen
alors
vous savez que moi j'appartiens à un
groupe dans le groupe identité
démocratique et même affilié au
rassemblement national et on est très
attaché à rester un peu dans notre réel
il est vrai que au conseil régional on
avait des sujets très ancrés dans le
quotidien en fait des franciliens et là
on s'en extrait plus on s'en extrait
complètement même pour avoir une vision
encore plus large plus européenne mais
j'estime que justement là il est des
grandes nécessités une grande salubrité
même mentale pour nos politiques un bon
députés européen n'est pas un député
européen qui passe sa vie à Bruxelles
c'est il doit absolument se reconnecter
au réel à se reconnecter avec son peuple
aussi mais les peuples européens en
général pour pour prendre la mesure des
véritables besoins parce que le travers
de l'Union européenne est peut-être de
nous faire vivre sous cloche alors je
sais pas si vous avez déjà montré votre
public à quoi ressemblait même les
locaux on voit pas souvent la lumière
tous les jours finalement et il faut
faire attention de ne pas bourgeoise
intéressante de faire cette transition
mais je n'oublie pas ce premier mandat
qui était
assez finalement salvateur pour
justement ce s'imprégner vraiment de ce
qu'est une le service à son peuple en
fait sur le terrain justement
l'actualité en France dimanche dernier
la nups a organisait une marche contre
la vie chère il revendique 140 000
participants la police elle parle de
30000 personnes la semaine a été marquée
par la grève aussi mardi dernier et
alors on nous en rejoint enregistrons
pardon cette émission la grève est
toujours en cours à Total et dans les
raffineries est-ce que vous comprenez ce
mécontentement qui qui monte un peu dans
dans le pays alors je voudrais découler
des décors et les le premier
contentement et la nuit épaisse
ce mécontentement il est là il existe il
est tout à fait justifié enfin voilà en
l'occurrence c'est vrai que vivre sous
le régime de la pénurie après avoir vécu
sous le régime de la peur du covid c'est
clairement pas ce qu'on veut pour le
notre quotidien pour nos enfants pour
nos parents enfin voilà une vie saine
c'est quand même une vie on a une vie
sociale mais on a aussi une vie
économique pérenne
concernant la marche contre la vie chère
parce que ça s'appelait comme ça et
l'inaction climatique c'était assez
marrant parce que alors du coup même
dans le titre il y a l'espèce de la
décoction permanente de cette gauche qui
revendique des fins de bon les gens les
personnes avec des revenus modérés qui
sont pas forcément les plus prompts à
vouloir justement cette espèce
d'écologie de façade que ne que prône la
gauche donc c'était assez intéressant et
sur les chiffres même de nombre de
manifestants il y a un vrai débat mais
je pense qu'en effet je lisais encore un
article hier je crois chez Marianne qui
disait Monsieur Mélenchon était
mécontent en effet de la mobilisation il
faut pas oublier que le camion qui
contenait les cadres aussi c'était très
drôle une espèce de je sais pas combien
de tonnes contre l'inaction climatique
qui soutenait les cadres de la dupesse
avait été hué par partie madame Rousseau
c'est clairement fait pas molesté mais
oui on a eu des mots violents contre
elle aussi au sein de la manifestation
parce que le vrai peuple de gauche
ce sont en quelque sorte trahi par ces
gens là qui sont finalement des
bourgeois du gauchisme en fait en
l'occurrence et je crois que l'exemple
que donne en ce moment les députés de la
nupesse au sein de notre Assemblée
nationale et très et tellement
caricatural que énormément de gens ne se
sentent plus représentés par ces gens-là
se disent que ils sont dans des espèces
de délires et des logiques
ultra féminisme et délirant c'est pas du
vrai féministe de défense de la femme de
l'écologie là aussi très idéologique
l'écologie est punitive de quota et
finalement d'exclusion des gens qui
justement voudraient lutter contre la
vie chère
donc c'est voilà pour moi c'était une
sorte de condensé un peu de toutes des
incohérences de gauche et dont le summum
a été finalement cette marche alors
parmi les sujets qui vous ont fait aussi
réagir sur Twitter il y a celui des edfe
ces zones à faible émission 10 métropole
les ont déjà mises en place dans ces
zones les véhicules donc les plus
polluants sont interdits de circuler
un rapport parlementaire récent coréigé
par d'ailleurs par le député moderne des
Yvelines Bruno Milène propose de mettre
en place un passe pour que ces véhicules
puissent circuler au moins deux fois
dans le mois vous vous êtes contre ces
zones faibles émission
oui parce que pour moi je suis fatiguée
voilà moi j'estime qu'il faut défendre
vraiment notre environnement ça
clairement la biodiversité qui va avec
mais ça ne passera pas par l'exclusion
d'une partie de la population je trouve
ça
igname en fait à partir du moment où
vous dites à certains
ben l'écologie c'est un sport de riche
donc sortez ça l'autre pauvre j'ai
beaucoup de mal avec ça en fait parce
que la réalité c'est ça ils ont beau nié
la réalité c'est ça c'est des gens qui
notamment dans les zones périphériques
rurales cherche des médecins cherche des
services publics non non plus donc sont
obligés d'aller en métropole et comment
font-ils souvent avec des véhicules qui
n'ont pas le critère établi par je ne
sais quel lobby peut-être en plus
automobile donc faut vraiment
s'interroger aussi là dessus je trouve
ça anormal moi les politiques qui
consistent à inclure à exclure une
partie de la ma population mes frères
mais voilà mais des Français pour moi
est une politique inique voilà comment
s'y prendre alors pour réduire le
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
en fait on arrête justement ce système
de métropolisation de notre monde parce
que avoir un pays qui est juste une un
désert temps de temps en temps ponctué
de métropole pleine de béton me semble
une aberration une aberration écologique
environnementale si vous vous triez un
environnement plus harmonieux ou d'un
nouvel alliance entre l'homme et la
nature c'est qu'un si vous le ferez
c'est à dire que c'est des agricultures
beaucoup plus raisonnées raisonnable
sur des parcelles au là aussi de taille
beaucoup plus raisonnable donc le plus
facilement gérable c'est réinscrire
remettre des services publics aussi dans
nos campagnes c'est aussi le seul moyen
d'éviter des exodes et donc d'éviter
l'entassement de population dans des
zones où foncièrement invivable enfin
maintenant vous allez vous vivez aux
abords du périph à part respirer des
modalités d'échappement
et qui ne cesse de s'empirer avec les
politiques justement dit écologiques de
Madame midalgo
non c'est voilà pour moi c'est c'est un
nom c'est une c'est de l'anti-écologie
c'est de
si ce qu'on appelle dans un très mauvais
français du griwashing c'est voilà il
faut arrêter vous voulez reverdir nos
vies cesser de les bétonner dans mon à
moi maintenant démarrera la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar alors beaucoup à gauche
appel au boycot de cette compétition
quel est votre composition au RN sur le
sujet
bon déjà la manière dont cette Coupe du
Monde a été attribué à ce pays au là
aussi où le respect des droits humains
est très très aléatoire c'est le mot est
faible je pense
oui on peut boycotter mais on peut
surtout peut-être même symboliquement je
sais alors là je m'avance
personnellement c'était mon parti
peut-être faire en sorte que la France
ni participe pas ça serait un un acte
très fort afin de dire clairement c'est
une affaire en plus très gênante sur
fond de allez on va éviter le mot qui
pourrait m'emmener entre un procès mais
peut-être de copinage qui ne justifie en
rien la tenue d'un tel événement sportif
dans ce pays-là alors pour finir un mot
sur le débat pour la présidence du
rassemblement national ça se poursuit
toujours un nouveau président sera nommé
le 5 novembre lors du congrès du parti
élu par les par les adhérents et
militants dans tout donc maintenant deux
semaines Jordan Bardella ou louer à Lyon
donc qui doit présider le parti selon
vous je crois
[Rires]
que ça fait longtemps que je connais
Jordan que un choix purement rationnel
qui est que on ne change pas une équipe
qui gagne en l'occurrence le binôme
marine Jordan m'a semblé le plus
efficace ces derniers mois
Jordan et pour moi l'avenir du
rassemblement national et donc je
souhaite le soutenir pleinement dans son
dans son élection alors vous avez obtenu
89 députés à l'Assemblée nationale le
rassemblement national en 2022 qu'elles
doivent être les prochains objectifs que
doit donc suivre le prochain président
du RN moi je pense qu'il doit absolument
[Musique]
entre guillemets entériner cette vague
quoi concrètement
l'agréger c'est victoires on prend goût
à la victoire en plus une victoire
souvent on appelle d'autres et
l'objectif c'est évidemment la
présidence de notre pays parce que
l'accélération l'affaissement de sur
tous les sujets économiques industriels
sécuritaire il y a une véritable urgence
et quand on aime la France bah voilà
c'est s'engager à la sauver je pense que
les personnes un peu lucides mais même
qui vivent dans leur quotidien la
violence avec laquelle les gouvernements
qui se sont succédés donc font vivre
nécessite un véritable changement et je
pense que très spontanément les Français
rationnels souhaitant un avenir français
auront l'occasion de nos nouveaux sortir
de soutenir jusqu'à 50 plus important au
projet des élections et pour boucler la
boucle revenons sur les européennes ce
qu'on les prochaines élections en 2024
en 2019 la liste de Jordan sujet là
avait récolté plus de 23% des voix avec
23 donc députés rassemblement national
quelles seront les objectifs en 2024 et
il y aura encore plus d'avantages de
députés ah oui de toute façon oui je
pense que 13 spontanément là aussi nous
grossirons encore nos rangs on sera ravi
d'accueillir de nouveaux collègues et
amis et surtout faire baisser le niveau
d'incompétence de reste la délégation
française qui était composée de Nathalie
Loiseau et d'autres qui j'espère
sortiront aussi vite qu'ils sont rentrés
la politique essayer de faire baisser la
suspension aussi alors c'est un
véritable enjeu qui est très
problématique parce que si nous avons un
devoir en tant que élu de faire
comprendre aux Français mais tous les
Européens alors l'occurrence pour les
européennes que si la haine ne
s'intéresse pas la politique eux en
revanche la politique s'intéresse
constamment à eux et s'ils veulent
vraiment changer leur vie il est
nécessaire qu'ils aillent voter
on suivra ça merci beaucoup Mathilde
que vous êtes député européenne du
rassemblement national et nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro délai plutôt politique
sera de sensation
[Musique]